Elon Musk is not a conventional CEO.
And he doesn’t run Tesla in a conventional
way.
In a previous video, I mentioned that Tesla
doesn’t advertise in a world where competitors
spend billions of dollars on commercials.
Tesla also doesn't have a Public Relations
team in North America.
That’s unheard of for a major corporation.
It means Tesla no longer reaches out to or
even responds to the media which is why in
a lot of articles you read about Tesla, you’ll
see something like this:
“Tesla didn’t immediately respond to a
request for comment.”
Usually, corporations have a PR team to send
positive news out to the media or to respond
to their questions.
When things go wrong, leaders depend on their
PR professionals to spin the message to mitigate
any damage.
But at Tesla, that hasn’t really been the
case since 2019.
Keely Sulprizio was the last person to officially
be in charge of global PR and communications
at Tesla.
She left the automaker in December 2019 to
join Impossible Foods.
Nearly every other member of Tesla’s PR
team reportedly left or moved to another position
within the company.
Tesla does have a small communications
presence in Europe
but not a global public relations department.
The big question is: why?
CEO Elon Musk has had some pretty harsh things
to say about the press.
He believes they treat Tesla unfairly and
once tweeted:
The holier-than-thou hypocrisy of big media
companies who lay claim to the truth, but
publish only enough to sugarcoat the lie,
is why the public no longer respects them.
For example, he called out the media for their
coverage of a Tesla collision in autopilot
mode that made headlines around the world.
He responded by saying:
It’s super messed up that a Tesla crash
resulting in a broken ankle is front-page
news.
In his view, what was actually amazing was
that the Model S hit a fire truck at 60 miles
an hour and the driver ONLY broke an ankle.
He was also frustrated at media coverage of
the much-hyped Battery Day event in September
2020 where Tesla unveiled it will manufacture
its own tabless batteries to improve range
and power, making a $25,000 car possible in
the future.
Several outlets pointed out there was disappointment
over a lack of an actual battery.
Here’s what Musk said when he appeared on
Kara Swisher’s podcast Sway.
The press coverage of this event of sad.
Okay, tell me why.
Most of the press takeaway was...
No battery.
A sad reflection of their understanding, really.
However, at the same time, journalists were
reportedly not allowed at the event and weren’t
able to ask questions.
They had to watch it remotely via Tesla’s
live stream along with everyone else.
The way Musk sees it, there is negative coverage
of Tesla because “journalists are under
constant pressure to get maximum clicks and
earn advertising dollars”.
He even suggested big oil is behind the negative
coverage since they are “among the world’s
biggest advertisers”.
He’s flirted with the idea of creating a
website where people can rate the credibility
of journalists and their news outlets which
he thought about calling Pravda - the Russian
word for “truth”.
Nothing came of that.
Since dissolving the PR department, Musk serves
as the PR department.
Much of his communication comes in the form
of tweets to his 58.5 million followers where
he responds to fans, posts news about his
company, and many memes these days, it seems.
He hasn’t embraced ALL social media, deleting
the Facebook pages of both Tesla and SpaceX
a few years ago and calling the social media
platform “lame”.
Musk does do the occasional interview with
the media - he hasn’t completely cut them
off.
Some argue he really should get a team behind
him.
Forbes made a pros and cons list, which, among
other things, pointed out a communications
wing could “prevent Musk from saying things
that could hurt the brand”.
Besides the pot-smoking on Joe Rogan’s
podcast, or his tweet about considering taking
Tesla private at $420 a share that got him
into trouble with the SEC, Musk has bragged
that Tesla cars would be able to drive themselves
anywhere, under any conditions by the end
of 2021.
In fact, he’s said for years that Tesla
is on the verge of Level 5 autonomy in which
no human interaction is needed whatsoever.
However, a public record obtained by the transparency
advocacy group PlainSite earlier this year
found that wasn’t the case.
This memo from the California Department of
Motor Vehicles notes, “Elon’s tweet does
not match engineering reality per CJ.”
That’s CJ Moore, director of autopilot software
at Tesla who had a conversation with the department
in March.
The memo went on to explain that “Tesla
indicated that Elon is extrapolating on the
rates of improvement when speaking about L5
capabilities” but notes at the time of the
meeting, Tesla was at Level 2.
Musk is known for his optimism, or as others
might suggest, his tendency to exaggerate.
But none of this appears to be hurting sales.
Tesla is selling cars as fast as they make’em.
In the second quarter of 2021, it produced
over 206,000 Model 3s and Model Ys and delivered
nearly as many.
The company has said it’s especially encouraged
by the popularity of the Model Y in China
where Tesla has been expanding rapidly.
And because of that expansion, someone asked
on Twitter whether a PR department may be
in the cards in the future.
To which Musk responded:
“Other companies spend money on advertising
& manipulating public opinion, Tesla focuses
on the product.
I trust the people.”
Musk will be in the history books for making
electric vehicles cool, fast, and perhaps
one day, affordable for the masses.
Regardless of whether Tesla has a PR department
or not, Musk always finds a way to make the
news.
If you want to stay up to date on the latest
news about Tesla, you can sign up for a FREE
newsletter.
My sponsor, Morning Brew, isn’t like
other newsletters that could be dense and boring.
It’s a short, daily newsletter full of informative
and relevant information about tech, business,
and finance, and takes only 5 minutes to read.
I recently learned about how a restaurant
is using robots powered by AI to fry and grill.
Again, Morning Brew is completely free and
takes less than 15 seconds to subscribe.
You can sign up by using the link in my description.
Doing so will also support this channel.
And feel free to let your family and friends
know as well.
Thanks so much for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.